there is an inadequate representation of  diversity  in our workplaces especially at the  decision-making level  and when decisions are taken from one  perspective the outcome does not serve  the whole of society  this is true for our public institutions  as it is for businesses ngos  banks universities and all components of  a particular society  this may we celebrate european diversity  month together with the members  of the eu platform of diversity charters  i call on workplaces all over the eu to  join our campaign  for more diversity and inclusion  if you are hosting a diversity event a  workshop  or a promotional campaign spread the  word i want to hear from you  it is high time our workplaces  represented our beautiful  and diverse europe in its entirety i  know that we can do this  thank you